hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to this is hollow head
hollow head was made for the ps1 game
Jim what a horrible dream I can't go
back to sleep just yet oh I can't can't
die why not what's waiting for me in my
dreams oh that's nice
Oh a hack for a living whoo I don't like
the way that door is all right cool hey
nice balcony don't like the way the
light burns everything I think I can
hear someone's voice wait a minute why
can I hear someone's voice in the vent
that's not what you want to hear that's
the opposite of what you want to hear Oh
something smells terrible
yeah no kidding what is it there's the
culprit better go take it out okay cool
where to where am I taking this right in
the toilet put in the toilet
put it right in the toilet you know I
guess now that I think about it the
voice in the vent could just be a
neighbor and nothing could be wrong
everything could be fine you know
actually now that I think about it I
don't think that everything's fine I
think that everything is actually not
fine did I just hear someone call for
help
sounds like it came from the garbage
room I better go check it out you know
call the police
somebody needs to call the police you
know I don't think it's my job for some
reason I just don't think it's my job
hey fastest way of the garbage room is
just down the chute ready okay through
my
oh oh [ __ ] separated my recyclables I
don't know where that flashlight came
from but I need it right now yeah no
joke Oh am I still going downstairs what
what am I going downstairs
Hey voices in the vents did you know
that something's wrong right now did you
know that there's problems in here you
guys might want to be a little concerned
about this conundrum that we're
operating under because there's bad
things afoot ooh oh ah this is my floor
good great why do I want to keep going
no do I have a choice are you giving me
a choice here are you giving me choices
oh are you giving me a choice
I don't think okay cool all right that's
fine that's totally fine totes mixed
grunts fine I don't remember the
basement being this way man whoever has
to live down here sure sucks for them
okay no don't do that
whatever you thinking about doing just
don't do it and we won't have a problem
we're not gonna have a problem if you
don't do it not sure where I'm going I
feel like I've been going in a bit of
circle yeah oh [ __ ] found a dead end
okay that's weird
oh no that's the way I started isn't it
oh god damn it how I gone in a circle
already oh [ __ ] I don't know why I
expected that to open but okay that's
just in here with me wonderful you know
I want to keep God how did I miss that
this whole time I've been wandering
around and I'm
that hello-o listen there's something
down here you gotta get out of here guys
whoever lives down here you gotta go
actually Oh down here okay you know if
we all team up I bet that thing whatever
it was won't stand a chance
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] I'm going towards it I'm going
towards it
oh [ __ ] no it won't give me not today
okay you know I love a good maze but
where am I going and why no I just went
in a big circle didn't I I bet this is
the way I came in
it is it is the way I came in god damn
it poets whoo
oh hi oh hey how are you doing
I caught him for you you know that's
great I'm gonna get you though
you can run you can hide but it's won't
stop till you kill the monster inside
oh well I killed the monster outside and
I think that's just as good all right so
that's all Oh head
Wow glad that worked out alright so this
next one's called ghost of tomorrow as
opposed to the ghost of today alright
well pretty standard fare Oh August 23rd
ooh it's in the future this is in the
future hello did I just get a ding dong
Alice I've been calling and texting you
for two days and you haven't answered I
haven't heard for anything from you for
days exactly two days where are you are
you okay please call me leaving that on
red talk about a needy mother I'm fine
mom
all right hello excuse me excuse me oh
[Music]
just my bathrooms on it it's just my
bathroom it's only in my bathroom it's
just the bathroom yeah good good to know
good to know that only my bathroom is
that way that that is hello hi okay cool
all right cool good good great
all right anyway is the ghost of
tomorrow gonna come out and say hi or
maybe the ghost of next Thursday is
gonna come out and say hi maybe the
ghost of Memorial Day pass is gonna come
out and say hi to me okay well I can't
leave so I guess I'm staying in Oh Alice
last seen outside Wyman University on
August 23rd wearing a white tank top and
jeans shorts brown eyes dark hair five
foot seven Oh they've been aged 24 okay
hey shut up in there
stop your crying we all got problems yes
hello hi is that my pizza I'm just gonna
go ahead it's not for me it's not
delivery its DiGiorno they got the
picture they got the message that's good
still weird in here hello listen I'm not
paying for it oh you oh wait you could
stop crying any day now you ain't gonna
get my sympathy okay whatever you say
hey why did that close when did that
door closed when did this door closed
what did they do I don't even suspect a
thing about it don't you
Oh brutally murdered you say missing
student found brutally murdered by
roommate roommate confesses murder
Alice grammar 2015 really there's this
Gail Rogers was the resident says he
confessed to committing the murder
doesn't major in film let's share two
bedroom I think Alice was girls only
friend okay Oh
hi oh hi okay listen
hello you suck how dare you make a good
horror game then rip it away from me how
dare you that was great that was that
was really really good just the way they
executed the scares was what it's a
one-time only thing like it won't be
scary the second time you do it but man
they really nailed those scares really
good stuff I like that a lot
okay next up fuzzy tomato that's not the
name of the game this one's called 6
a.m. now why it's called 6 a.m. I'm not
a hundred sure find the first floor and
leave the building simple as that
third floor you say well I'm looking for
the first key card all right cool
that's alright easy there's no way that
I won't be able to get that I'm sorry
what's that a giant spider your mind to
believe that there's giant spiders
crawling all over this floor because if
so that's ridiculous that is regard am
Nicholas first floor hey what's that the
shadow of a giant spider or was I
gravely mistaken with my own idiocy
I have deluded myself into thinking that
there are giant spiders crawling all
over the place in this office because
that'd just be ridiculous
now fool me thrice shame on vice because
I do declare my eyes doth not save me
when I think there are giant spiders
crawling every which way in this
building then again I might be a fool
who smoked far too much PCP for my own
good who's to say not I the only person
inside this building
besides the giant spiders that may or
may not be figments of mine urn
imagination anybody well I'll just mosey
on forward
think I'm going crazy too many horror
games or too many spiders don't know
which ones more true please the front
doors Frick family friendly please the
doors are locked
I need to get to Adams office so I can
unlock floor 3 you know ok find the
second floor manager's office you got it
baby
hey is that a keycard oh yeah nice all
right
time to mosey on back up because
everything's looking up for me now hold
on a second here
what the hell is that ok the spider hair
am I supposed to well now that may have
been a fever dream for my repeated
exposure to the various recreational
drugs I take in frivolous occasions
aliens in addition to a horde of giant
spiders crawling towards me menacingly
and then staring at me directly in my
eyes
both the shifts ronke what are these
voices talking in my mind why would I
need to run surely that is not an
urgency that I need to address surely I
can take all the time that i doth desire
yeah ok the second floor East Wing why
that's it yeah
it is very clearly job where did he live
the Siraj sugar desk she sits next to me
okay where do I sit
that's I don't remember where giant
spider probably well I need to check
Sarah's desk I keep getting eaten alive
by these spiders but no they will not
get the best of me because of all the
drugs I've taken I am practically immune
Oh
the spiders to ask me you silly [ __ ] I
shall not die to you there is my
objective stupid spider you've been
fooled by my Kevin who's anyway
time to go back into the manager's
office I'm gonna stop doing that voice I
don't know why I'm doing it in the first
place can't help it
sometimes I just have to listen to my
brain be weird hey I got the keycard I
got it I got the keycard what's the
dealio I got the keycard
I swear I did I gotta stop getting my
ankles nibbled off oof roblox poof
indeed so jump over it that's that's
apparently the strategy okay a leap okay
leapfrog don't work so good well I got
the keycard then what is it open hey
spider you dumbass okay you eek okay Wow
you know they can't all be winners you
can have two great good horror games and
then you can have things kind of fall
apart at the end and you know it's fine
that's the way it goes you take the good
with the bad and if this is what this is
gonna be then this is what it's gonna be
but man this yeah a little number one
when I say this first off
choose your monsters correctly
may have a fear of spiders but it
doesn't translate very well into a
videogame unless you do it correctly and
even then you're really not gonna get
the essence of what makes that spider
terrifying number two don't show your
monster too much you get accustomed to
the monster and if it's not a scary
monster in the first place then they're
gonna lose all threat number three make
the respawn mechanic that forgiving
because it's just too forgiving like
there's no way that there could be any
threat to it because of the way it is
oh hi alien I finally see you now in the
corner over there you're weird jiggly
head oh I see both of you what are you
doing over there you're weirdos I'm sure
there's more to this game story wise but
it's too bright you can see too much
it's too flat it's too even the whole
key card a bunch of key cards in the
same office doesn't make any sense
because it's just weird gating mechanic
to try to get you through the same
environment instead of moving to
different environments and all of our
environments look the same anyway so it
kinda just makes it very blase that
being said you know everyone has to
start somewhere with horror and you know
you got to start somewhere it didn't
work this idea but that doesn't mean
that you can't keep going in with it you
take what you learned from this and you
apply to the next one so I'm gonna leave
it there if you want to play any of
these horror games for yourself I'll put
links in the description thank you
everybody for watching and thank you all
developers for taking the time to make
these wonderful games and if you want to
see any more scary games that I have
played check the description or
subscribe and ring that bell to be
notified of when and where and why I
will be uploading more horror games in
the future thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I'll see you
in the next video
[Music]